[Applaudissements]
2.0 bonjour votre système de
surveillance vient d'être mise à jour
il est au courant est-ce que vous avez
bien su le mail non irak l'ont pas reçue
bonsoir et dabo spam deux soirs donc
dans ce mail il écrit quoi il est écrit
que toutes les facettes de votre vie à
partir de maintenant vous être surveillé
de manière continue rampant sa
surveillance on pense souvent à caméras
de surveillance aux mes copains me
disent caméras de surveillance
c'est souvent pour les délinquants où je
peux les terroristes ça me concerne pas
trop moi j'ai rien à me reprocher j'ai
un très bon citoyen tout va bien je
pensais comme eux qui m'est arrivé une
petite histoire il ya vingt ans et je
veux la partager avec vous or ya vingt
ans je faisais des recherches sur
l'intelligence artificielle gm thèse
dans ce truc là or ce truc là ça un
carrefour intelligente
on avait deux caméras vidéos surveiller
le trafic routier et on essayer de
repérer tous les anomalies qui pouvait y
avoir sur ce trafic routier
pour cela on reconstituait la
trajectoire de chaque véhicule
et dès qu'il y avait un soupçon
d'anomalies on envoie une image un
opérateur humain
l'opérateur humains ils regardent image
au la voiture mal stationnée au mauvais
endroit
hop on appelle la dde il ya un accident
on regarde la gravité si c'est un
accident grave
j'appelle les pompiers sinon la police
voyez ça se faisait à peu près comme ça
le site a marché relativement bien un
matin j'arrive au labo le système rouge
rouge vif alors je regarde l'anomalie
georges raiarii caméra et l'anomalie
c'était une jolie femme sur le trottoir
alpha monsoise cpai de l'anomalie 1
non mais son comportement par contre à
perturber beaucoup le train le trafic
bon je vous situe un peu donc on a deux
autres femmes couche de très courtes par
esi talons hauts ou jussiê pigeonnant
fait des signes aux voitures les
voitures stationnent devant elle elle
discute avec le conducteur
voyez donc aperture trafic tout ça et
puis à voiture repart donc je regarde
j'y tiens c'est prenant j'avais jamais
vu bon bon ça va marcher donc je décide
d'aller la voir puisque ça m'intrigue et
un peu quand même
j'arrive bonjour à l'oisel vous êtes
surveillés par des caméras vidéo voyez
c'est un carrefour espère mental et
surtout vous troubler mon système
informatique
[Rires]
donc ça l'a fait un peu rire et puis
j'ai eu mon bac es ce qu'elle fait sur
ce carrefour quoi et lava grande
surprise raconte une histoire
elle prépare un jeu avec des amis il ya
deux équipes et elle redirige les
véhicules selon deux lieux différents
enfin quand je m'étais trompé sur son
activité
alors en 99
heureusement pour elle les systèmes
informatiques ne sont pas capables de
reconnaître le comportement sur
l'infrastructure routière des humains
aucune machine tk pas de le faire
en 99 par contre aujourd'hui en 2019
il ya des intelligences artificielles
qui sont capables de reconnaître
certains comportements dans la rue et
surtout elles sont capables de vous
identifier en commun on s'identifie en
général dans la vie courante en général
ben on a des cartes d'identité des
permis de conduire des cartes vitale on
ça c'est moi
et en général avec ça on a des droits
droit d'être citoyen droit de conduire
droit d'être soigné puis des devoirs
font respecter code civil péter le code
de la route
bref alors ça c'est dans la vie réelle
mais sur internet se passe comment
l'identification en général ça commence
par login et un mot de passe
alors si ça s'arrête là c'est très bien
on est dans le nom de l'anonymat vous
pouvez créer autant de logging autant de
mots de passe que vous voulez autant de
comptes que vous voulez d'accord mais
rapidement vous demande autre chose vous
demande votre nom votre prénom votre
date de naissance votre genre on
commence à vous classez vous êtes une
jeune femme entre 25 et 35 ans renvoyé
on commence à vous proposer peut-être
des services sur mesure
et puis on va vous demander vos goûts
vos compétences votre numéro de
téléphone
ah là ça se complique un peu le numéro
de téléphone
parce que on met 33 devant
l'identification de la france et vous
avez allure au mondial sur what's app ou
switch hâte
vous remarquez qu'on vous demande de
plus en plus votre numéro de téléphone
ouais parce que en plus on vous
géolocalise c'est quand même sens
exactement vous êtes et puis on vous
propose de donner votre carte bancaire
alors là c'est votre comportement des
acheteurs de consommateurs qui commence
à être suivi
et puis aux fournisseurs internet du
texte des vidéos des photos alors sur
chacune de ses photos
bah on va commencer à identifier nous
contacter nos meilleurs amis nos enfants
j'ai pas pu confessa dont le fait et
puis à partir de là le système est
capable de nous reconnaître de manière
automatique
chacune des photos qui arrive sur google
photo ou sur iphoto est analysée là il
ya un enfant qui entre à souffler des
bougies huit bougies sur un gâteau au
chocolat l'enfant l'a déjà identifié 37
fois c'est à dire qu'on a fait ce qu'on
appelle des index toutes les photos que
vous diffusée sur internet sont analysés
et transformez vous pouvez aller sur
google photos par exemple et demandé
trouve moi parmi mes photos toutes les
photos et un gâteau au chocolat
l'information est donnée de manière
instantanée
a déjà été calculé les photos sont
stockées et le contenu des photos aussi
sont stockées alors on va pas s'arrêter
là
on va aussi analyser vos comportements
sur internet vos clics vos recherches
vos achats et puis sur les achats vos
évaluations sur les achats les
commentaires sur les achats tout ça
c'est me et stocker enregistré etc
et puis dans like évidemment nos fameux
like alors maintenant ils sont un petit
peu améliorée on est en colère on est
triste c'est un peu puéril mais ça
marche super bien ça marche bien pour
eux parce que ils peuvent commencer à
vous identifier
ils ont embauché on va en parler on va
parler de lui le prêt ils ont embauché
des psychologues sociologues
anthropologues pour commencer à bien
acide et vos profils chacun de nos
profils vont être analysés par exemple
peut-être que vous identifier
dernièrement alors qu'au profil tous les
sens de profit d'un tendances
religieuses tendances politiques
votre santé vous consommation tout est
bien analysé peut-être qu'aujourd'hui
vous avez été analysé comme pervers
narcissique ou prostituées ou obsédé du
cassoulet depuis quelques temps on va en
plus ajouter quelque chose on va
analyser le réel c'est à dire qu'on va
avoir des outils des google omd alexa
des téléphones portables qui vont vous
écouter chez vous et puis on y rajoute
bien sûr les caméras vidéo avec les
caméras vidéo ça devient carrément
intrusif
on vous reconnaît on vous identifie dans
la rue dans les supermarchés dans les
bancs et évidemment ce qui vient ce que
qui est associé à ça c'est qu'on va
fusionner votre identité réelle avec
votre identité numérique
vous ne pourrez plus dire que vous aviez
plusieurs identités numériques s'est
terminée ce que je viens de vous
annoncer la aujourd'hui c'est tout
simplement la fin de l'anonymat
c'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui j'ai
un plan b g le plomber l'ambiance là
alors on va voir si vous êtes concerné
qui ici s'est connecté cette semaine sur
un de ces réseaux
tout le monde avait la main bon de
manière unanime on est concerné vous
vous sentez sous influence ou pas vous
sentez que pilote un peu votre vie oui
un petit peu oui parce que déjà leur
façon de fonctionner qu'est ce que c'est
vendre de la publicité a puisé une
influence c'est vous dire tiens tu
devrais acheter ça plutôt que ça et ses
cibles et s'est classé en fonction de
votre mode de consommation ou plutôt du
profil du consommateur
c'est là où les intelligences
artificielles commencent à agir on va
vous prendre vos super profil je veux
donner plein de l'information sur ces
profils ont même construit de nouveaux
de nouvelles informations
et puis on va vous comparer entre vous
et puis étonné qu'on est très très
nombreux ils peuvent commencer à savoir
quel goût de films vous aimez sûr d'être
flix on va vous proposer ce film là
parce que vous êtes partis les gens qui
aiment tous ces films là qu'ils
détestent tout cela oui j'ai tous les
films vous avez été au milieu et que
vous avez pris à l'autre il est ensuite
envoyé sa j'estime qu'on n'aime pas et
puis tout ce groupe là à aimer ce film
au lard et celui là voulaient pas vu hop
on vous le propose c'est comme ça que
marche tous les moteurs de
recommandation
ils vont même plus loin ils sont
capables de prédire l'achat que vous
allez faire cette modèle d'amazon
c'est à dire qu'on est capable de mettre
dans le après visionner le stock à côté
de chez vous dans le produit que vous
allez acheter demain salaire de la magie
mais ça marche super bien à los angeles
il livre les canapés en quatre heures ça
donne un peu le niveau
alors est-ce qu'il ya d'autres
influences que la consommation
j'ai envie de dire oui on est influencé
aussi dans ce cas plus intimes
notre cerveau enfin côte quand vous
cherchez de l'information sur internet
vous allez vers des vérités qui vous
plaisent et vous allez confirmer vos
vérités ces principes de l'apprentissage
j'ai appris quelque chose je veux
vérifier que cette chose là existent et
puis je vais lire le maximum
d'informations qui concerne ma vérité
sauf que je suis pas tout seul sur
internet il ya des
il ya des grosses boîtes qui vont les
avions on les a vus là qu'ils regardent
tous mes gestes sur internet vise haut
mais il aime bien ce cette vérité là
j'ai pas par exemple imaginons que je
crois qu'on l'a jamais été sur la lune
il ya pleins d'articles là dessus bon
bah naturellement google va me toucher
de l'information sur le fil d'actualité
de tous les hommes quand pas été sur la
lune avec des preuves etc etc
et naturellement ça va confirmer mes
connaissances un jour j'ai passé deux
trois heures à regarder star war j'aime
bien star war dont j'avais pleins
d'articles maintenant sur mon flux
d'actualités google sur l'un de mes
profil il ya toujours un article star
wars et le jour où il ya une information
majeure sur star wars
mon fils d'information c'est que du star
wars il ya eu d'autres informations
c'est à dire les problèmes climatiques
politique sociologique on oublie
complètement
je suis emballé dombasle est dans une
espèce de bulle d'information qu'elle a
bu star war alors ça a l'air très
intrusif comme sa pire on se méfie par
alors la solution évidemment c'est
d'avoir plusieurs profils puis commencé
à être un peu ouverts ou à développer
son esprit critique par rapport à ça oui
on est on est drôlement sur influence
dernièrement ils ont montré que
l'élection du bric site et de trump les
réseaux sociaux ont été des facteurs des
acteurs vraiment majeur pour développer
cette vote donc on peut même influencer
les gens sur leur vote
alors la chine à la d'essayer de peut
être ne pas être influencé par les
réseaux sociaux américains
d'autres ils ont dit déjà tous qui
réseau social américain dehors d'accord
ans ils ont privilégié leur leur réseau
âge et dans ce réseau ils ont commencé à
se dire tiens si on commençait a alors
cédé test pour l'instant sur terre
certaines villes en chine à mettre un
autre sociale chaque citoyen va avoir
une note social ces notes de bonne
conduite
c'est à dire que si vous respectez bien
la loi ben vous avez vous être
récompensés le problème c'est quand vous
la respectais pas là ça prend c'est un
petit peu plus confier votre notre
social va baisser
par exemple vous mangez un sticker sur
le métro on s'est interdit à shanghai
donc vous avez autre sociale qui baisse
vous passez au passage piéton avec le
petit bonhomme rouge là c'est interdit
ça c'est pas bien
et on s'est toujours en france et pas en
chine hop on est flashé votre photo est
affichée sur les murs de la ville vous
avez le droit à une amende et votre mot
social baisse et c'est respect du code
civil là c'est juste par contre le
presse c'est que l'aide sociale
si elle baisse il va y avoir des droits
au moins un moment donné vous n'aurez
plus droit de voyager voudrait plus
droit de prétendre à certains emplois et
vous ne pourrez pas inscrire vos enfants
à certaines universités
voilà le modèle chinois alors et nous en
europe on fait quoi on fait rien puisque
de façon on n'a pas de réseaux sociaux
l'outil des réseaux des autres ça c'est
un peu gênant c'est un peu gênant parce
que moi je dis qu'on fait rien alors les
dernières on a on a construit le rgp des
ça vous dit quelque chose
la régulation des données personnelles
c'est à dire qu'on va donner des droits
vous êtes droit d'exiger de voir vos
data alors on vous donne des gigas data
j'ai demandé à apple en a geagea
position de chaque antenne ou le
téléphone s'est connecté
j'ai pas trop quoi en faire en tant que
citoyen je me dis ouais super bon j'ai
un deuxième droit c'est dire à une
entreprise par exemple un opérateur
téléphonique
ça fait dix ans que tu es avec moi
toutes les dates à que tu as chez toi tu
les donne à l'autre opérateur et il
oublie on peut transférer nos données ça
il faut l'utiliser n'y a pas de raison
la concurrence est fait pour ça et puis
ensuite on oublie ça coûte c'est pas des
lois que j'aurai en vue mais en tant que
citoyen en tant que citoyen je voudrais
des outils je voudrais comprendre qu'ils
font avec les datas je veux savoir les
entreprises qui utilisent mes dates à
tous les jours et qu'est ce qu'ils en
font en termes d' usage
je veux comprendre métro fils en
profondeur alors je suis conscient que
toutes les intelligences artificielles
c'est assez génial pour résoudre
énormément de problèmes je parle qu'une
petite partie qui m'inquiète un peu ce
que je vous propose moi c'est de se dire
bon qu'est ce qui nous manque en europe
il nous manque quoi il nous manque un
réseau social qu'on pourrait faire
ensemble dont définirait le contenu les
règles et les usages que je puisse avoir
un tableau de bord de mes données
personnelles et que ce réseau social
permet de voir
profil complet tous les traitements qui
sont associés les usages 2b données et
surtout je veux pouvoir tout contrôler
je veux pas que cette emprise utilise
une partie b data jeu l'empêchent je
veux ce droit là on peut le faire
techniquement ça pose aucun problème
c'est juste un prêt une influence
politique qui veut se lancer là dessus
et je pense que nous en tant que citoyen
on pourrait vraiment créer c'est quelque
chose de sympa ça pourrait être un
réseau public
on pourrait voter pour et moi je
prendrais surement plus de confiance
dans un réseau public
on aurait construit ensemble plutôt
qu'un réseau privé qui nous prive de
notre identité
voyez ça c'est vraiment ça me pose une
grosse difficulté alors la transparence
de transparence et pour conclure j'ai
envie de dire quoi bah je vous demande
juge exige ou exigeons plus tôt ensemble
la transparence sur nos données la
transparence sur nos sur de traitement
et puis le thème du ted c'est des
acteurs du changement b secteur du
changement c'est nous et sur cela je
vous souhaite tout
tout était tout une très belle mise à
jour merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]